so there there's a couple of other small
companies
um
called google and apple
so google is now using its own chip for
the pixel six
apple using is its own
how does qualcomm out compete
google
and apple how does it beat them we don't
have to out compete google actually if
you look at our mobile strategy today
and then one thing i was very clear when
i became ceo i think there's a lot of
confusion on the market our mobile
strategy is very clear
we are focused of making snapdragon
synonymous with premium android
experience
that's what snapdragon is android the
bone of the people
yes um
i just have a love for android no i'm
constantly talking trash to iphone
people sorry go ahead premium android
experiences so
we do pre we do produce snapdragon and
multiple tier for every price point but
you know every year you mentioned the uh
eight gen one and every year we provide
you know the flagship product and then
and then the other series that is trying
to get the best of every possible
technology at that time and it's really
focused
on enabling the android ecosystem so
i'll give an example so you asked me the
question how to compete with google it's
not about competing with google we're
the number one enabler of the google
android
ecosystem and the largest
largest the number one customer there is
actually samsung
and if you look what happened to samsung
samsung
i always had
since i i began my began my relationship
with them that because they always had
their own chip they always had their own
chip
and um and if you'll just look at what
happened right now with the galaxy s22
that just launched you know they used to
balance their their business about 50
qualcomm they will get the most advanced
markets like the united states and china
and japan and korea they will sign a
qualcomm and then they have their own
chip for the markets that they would
will be like more emerging markets open
markets markets that they have a control
on the channel because they sell a lot
of appliances and other things if you
look what happened right now gs22 uh 75
uh
is qualcomm
and uh and then the next
large oems and android system are the
chinese ones uh companies like xiaomi uh
one of the fastest growing uh it was
number one in europe at some point uh
last year then followed by oppo and
oneplus and vivo so those are some of
the largest qualcomm customers and uh
and they actually drive
the android ecosystem and that's your
mobile strategy in fully align with
google and uh
and it's working and i was you know i'm
not to get into a lot of the
uh investor conversation but uh we're
also happy we became
uh
in a beneficiary of the shifts that we
saw in the marketplace as huawei
became a smaller oem as a result of the
sanctions
we saw the rise of a lot of the other
oems from china especially for china
domestic market xiaomi oppo vivo they
moved to the premium category and
they're all doing that with qualcomm so
uh we're actually very fortunate and
happy with the position we are in mobile
business we do have an apple
relationship we provide modem technology
to apple
it's a multi-year relationship apple has
been very public that they are
investing to develop their own modem
but the qualcomm strategy has has been
clear you know we'll really focus on
snapdragon you know not our mobile
strategy is not defined by providing a
cellular modem to apple or mobile
strategies this would just talk about it
it's about the unique thing of
snapdragon that has every single
technology integrated into a single soc
and
it provides a premium experience and
that's what we're doing and
focusing on the android ecosystem
you